[Music]
maps to the stars is directed by David
Cronenberg and stars Julianne Moore and
John Cusack amongst a lot of other
people like Robert Pattinson and if I
were to sum up this movie in one
sentence which believe me is extremely
hard to do I would say it is a basically
the movie follows a group of different
people whose paths intersect in various
ways some of them are trying to make it
into Hollywood and some of them are
already in Hollywood the movie takes a
look at the way people in Hollywood may
or may not act some of the strange
things that are pushed under the rug
some of the sayings that people in
Hollywood say that might shock you
certain things that David Cronenberg is
trying to say about the state of
Hollywood and the mindset of really
famous people who love being famous but
it's not just a satire on Hollywood or a
parody of what Hollywood tropes are like
it's a ghost movie - yeah it's a ghost
movie as well
no guys if you're fans of David
Cronenberg do you guys know exactly what
to expect all of his movies at one point
or maybe throughout the entire thing you
are thinking what the hell is going on
I'm actually a huge fan of some of his
work I adore the fly I love Eastern
Promises and I also loved a history of
violence I really enjoyed a lot of his
movies and even the ones that weren't
that great all have this intense visual
crispness to them that blow me away
every time with the images he's able to
get and this movie is very narrative ly
jumbled I mean it's everywhere the tone
shifts all the time but I have to be
completely honest part of me was
mesmerized by this movie it's a two hour
movie filled with what could be viewed
as nonsense and incredibly annoying
characters in fact a lot of them really
are but the movie is making a point with
a lot of these characters showing the
way that a lot of Hollywood celebrities
act and how truly debase their lifestyle
is now it's not saying that every
celebrity is like this but there are
people like that out there I think one
of the biggest in your face moments this
movie is when these celebrity kids are
sitting around literally talking about
I mean like they're actually
talking about excrement but to me
Cronenberg and the screenwriter we're
basically just saying a lot of these
celebrities just sit around and talk
about both
that's all they do is just
and it's true but as I
said a large portion of this movie his
character is hallucinating and seeing
ghostly images and these ghostly images
are talking to these characters and
making them feel extremely upset about
their pasts and all the characters have
various things that intersect them in
some ways and in typical Cronenberg
style it's always some very violent or
odd sexual thing and that's what he does
with all of his movies lots of visceral
violence and strange sex stuff and
there's a lot of that throughout this
movie as well in this film continues his
ongoing theme of bending reality there's
large portions of this movie where
you're actually wondering if it ever
took place or if it was just a
hallucination or if it's all part of
some hidden visual metaphor of one of
the characters heads I mean when I saw
enemy with Jake Gyllenhaal I was blown
away by it it really took me by surprise
and it took me two months to decipher
that film and really try to figure out
what it was about and I felt like I was
able to do that with my enemy explain
video but when the film ended despite my
mind being boggled I still felt like it
all made sense the things that I had
just seen were a logical progression of
events that led to something that made
sense I gotta be honest I don't feel
that way with maps to the stars I'm sure
there's a lot of hidden things that I
did not notice on my first viewing and
that I would appreciate more the second
time but there are a lot of characters
in this movie that feel completely out
of place that don't feel like they
actually add something to the theme of
the movie and feel like they actually
detract from what could be a good theory
about what the movies actually about I'm
trying to avoid spoilers as I describe
this so I apologize if I'm confusing you
as well my point being is that this
movie definitely had my attention I
enjoyed the performances John Cusack was
very good Julianne Moore was excellent
Robert Pattinson was also very good I
liked all of the actors work in this
movie but I don't quite feel like it's a
hundred percent whole I feel like
there's a lot missing here and I feel
like certain things aren't there that
should be there for us to ever really
fully decipher this movie also there's
some really questionable CGI towards the
end that I don't know it just it really
took me out of the movie so I got to
give maps to the stars a B
- now the reason I'm giving it a
positive is because I was interested I
think some of the performances are
really good and I think it's a great
looking movie but as a whole it is
missing certain pieces that I think are
needed for the film to make a hundred
percent sense so guys if you do see this
movie I'd really like to know what your
thoughts are because I think this is the
kind of movie that can really benefit
from a lot of discussion also I know I
know I am being slow on this but I
promised I would review the show kids on
the slope it's a really great anime show
and I'm going to I'm going to in March I
promise I've just had so many videos to
do but I thought it'd be really cool
this time if I did something a little
bit different how often do you guys
actually get to see what I'm gonna
review before I talk about it this isn't
a common thing usually I'm reviewing a
new release that's not quite out yet
this time I would love if you guys could
actually watch the show kids on the
slope before I review it and I'm running
a promotion right now with
crunchyroll.com and you can do that
crunchyroll and I are offering you guys
30 days of crunchyroll for free it's an
anime streaming service filled with HD
anime and no ads straight from Japan
almost instantly sometimes within just a
few hours you get some of these new
shows and this is a site that's crafted
by anime fans anime is really important
to me and I feel like it'd be really
cool if you guys got to watch this show
before I actually review it so if you'd
like to do that you can go to
crunchyroll.com slash Chris stuckman and
get 30 days of this service for free
that's my gift to you guys from
crunchyroll as well we want to team up
we want to do more anime reviews so
definitely check out kids on the slopes
see if you like it and I'm gonna be
talking about it next month that's
crunchyroll.com slash Chris stuckman
guys thank you so much as always for
watching pretty soon I'm going to have a
hilarious 'ti review for Batman and
Robin with my buddy the flick pick John
Flickinger can't wait to bring that to
you guys as well as reviews for outcasts
with Nicolas Cage and still Alice with
Julianne Moore as always guys if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck menage
[Music]